Euglena is a genus of single cell flagellate eukaryotics.
It is the best known and most widely studied member of the class Euglenoidea,...
...a diverse group containing some 54 genera and at least 800 species.
Species of Euglena are found in freshwater and salt water.
They are often abundant in quiet inland waters...
...where they may bloom in numbers...
...sufficient to color the surface of ponds and ditches green or red.
The species Euglena gracilis has been used extensively in the laboratory as a model organism.
Most species of Euglena have photosynthesizing chloroplasts within the body of the cell,...
...which enable them to feed by autotrophy, like plants.
However, they can also take nourishment heterotrophically, like animals.
Since Euglena have features of both animals and plants,...
...early taxonomists, working within the Linnaean three-kingdom system...
...of biological classification,...
...found them difficult to classify.
It was the question of where to put such "unclassifiable" creatures...
...that prompted Ernst Haeckel to add a third living kingdom to the Animale,...
Vegetabile of Linnaeus: the Kingdom Protista.